welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn Wilkes your host and our guest
is Stephen B Smith the elephant Cole's
professor of political science and
co-director of the Center for the Study
of representative institutions at the
Macmillan Center which focuses on the
theory and practice of representative
government in the anglo-american world
his research interests include the
history of political philosophy with
special attention to the problem of the
Ancients and moderns the relation of
religion and politics and theories of
representative government his best-known
publications include Spinoza's Book of
Life the Cambridge companion to Leo
Strauss and political philosophy today
we'll speak with professor Smith about
his new book modernity and its
discontents making and unmaking the the
bourgeois from Machiavelli to Bello
welcome professor's now it's my pleasure
nice to be here with y'all thank you
let's begin with an overview of your
book tell us about it okay the book grew
out of a very simple question ask the
question why is the United States the
most powerful prosperous and freest
country in the world
why are we so continually be set by
discontent that's the broad very broad
question the book tries to ask and it
tries to do so not by looking at the
certain usual suspects which you know
congressional dysfunction or the
direction of the economy or something
like this it really looks more deeply at
the question of the kind of civilization
that the modern West has produced the
civilization that I I call not my own
term obviously that I call boudoir
civilization we have produced the modern
West a unique and special kind of human
individual the bourgeois and all of that
all that that represents what does that
represent
gonna get today I'm glad you asked I get
it and most of what I call in the book
are discontents derive from this the
emergence of this tight okay
what is the bushwa I it's a familiar
term and in some some respects probably
most famously but but not only
associated with the name of Karl Marx
although that's not particularly the way
I use the term in the book the bourgeois
is a character type every society I
argue produces a distinctive character
type the warrior the priest the hero
whatever we we our our modern society
has produced its own character type
unprecedented in human history called
the bourgeois it's began to emerge in
the 16th and 17th century and the book
deals with early iterations of the
expression of this of this character
type and works by people like
Machiavelli and Rene Descartes and and
Thomas Hobbes and so on but the
bourgeois is originally emerged as a the
idea of sort of free and responsible
individual unbe holden to guild or
church or neighborhood or fiefdom any
particular association it was due to be
to be the bullet the bush war was a new
kind of human being on the face of the
earth someone who was their own person
unbound by tradition and authority free
to make themselves and become themselves
and of course the kind of classic
bourgeois story which I discussed in the
book is is it works something like
Benjamin Franklin's autobiography the
story of the self-made man a person who
you know unbe Holden makes themselves to
be what they are it's a heroic in many
ways it's a very heroic picture and yet
at the same time I want to argue it was
the very success of this character type
that has produced a reaction to it and a
kind of anti bourgeois backlash you
might say that began also around the mid
to late 18th century we can get into
that and which received philosophical
literary and political expression and
throughout the 19th and the 20th century
in this phenomenon of the kind of anti
bushwa and that took many many forms but
those are those are the sources or that
is this unique source i want to argue of
the kind of discontent that we are so
beset with with today that underlies I
think that the various currents of you
know contemporary dissatisfaction with
ourselves ok when you use the term
modern you know what do you mean by that
yeah
modern yes I mean we all naturally think
of ourselves as modern men and women
people at people of today the concept of
modernity which is a philosophical term
is really something that we typically
not always but I think typically trace
back to the sixteenth seventeenth
centuries with again the emergence of
not only this new type of individual and
I've been describing but of course a
whole new kind of society which would
give support and sustenance to that kind
of individual what do I mean by that a
kind of bourgeois civilization that with
which is associated with modernity I
mean by that a society that validates
scientific modes of investigation
science and technical unfettered uses of
science and technology as a marker of
human progress
the conception related to this for
example of the marketplace the emergence
of the market and market society is the
sort of definitive allocators of you
know goods and services and of course
the emergence of related phenomena the
phenomenon of we think of a
secularization a religious world that we
think has now become somewhat privatized
and no longer holds the dominant force
that it had in earlier times and and
needless to say the
beginning of modern democratic
representative political institutions
these are all the distinctive features
that structural institutional forms that
that modernity is taken and I talked
about some of it at various points about
all of these in the book but what most
it most interests me again is the unique
type of human being that this society
produces the bourgeois the modern
individual and again the both the in
many ways it is one of our most precious
achievements of the modern world
definitely and yet it is the source of
so much anxiety fear anxiety and
discontent that we now feel so in your
preface you state modernity is a problem
right what do you mean by that
okay well it's draws on a bit of what
I've just been saying I mean we we have
we typically get a kind of heroic
conception of the modern world based on
the kind of Enlightenment story that
modernity begins with with the end of
this kind of futile and backward period
the kingdom of darkness and we've been a
slowly progressively moving into an
enlightened world of freedom and
democracy and science and progress a
progressive narrative of human history
that's the way the story is is typically
told what I want to argue is that in a
way is only at best half the story
and it's a story that's come under
increasing pressure in the you know the
last century certainly a pressure that
began early on early on people extremely
prescient Minds began to see that
modernity was a problem and in my own
book I traced that back to Rousseau
jean-jacques Rousseau it's a crucial
chapter on Rousseau who was the first to
pinpoint that this new civilization
which he by the way was I believe the
first to define as the boudoir world
saw it in his own way as a world of
falseness do
implicitly hypocrisy this was behind all
of the you know refined development
progressive developments we have he
applied an absolutely brutal we call
moral critique to the to this to this
phenomenon the world that was supposed
to be governed by the mechanisms of
self-interest in the hidden hand of
economics Rousseau exposed as false and
duplicitous and in many ways Russo's
powerful critique took hold in a number
of many right many writers in the
nineteenth and twentieth century who
took this in in very different
directions some like Marx who was very
much in this respected disciple of
Rousseau saw the world of the modern
market society once again is alienating
and exploit aid exploitative and
oppressive of the working class but mark
still very much bought in to the
Enlightenment conception the modern
conception of progress and he did see in
the future in a purely enlightened
rational world which was highly utopian
and fantastic idea but other writers
other other thinkers in many ways took
Russo's critique in a different way that
I mean they came to believe that the
whole world of modern democracy and
modern science was somehow rotten and
what was needed people in the generation
after the French Revolution like the the
French writer Joseph de Maistre and of
course most famously in the 19th century
read with Nietzsche and others began to
see this what this world's is rotten and
and not just in need of fulfilling the
Enlightenment dream but radically
undermining there was a kind of nihilism
that was also in in some respects not an
intended but I think an unanticipated
result of kind of Russo's devastating
critique of the modern bourgeois and in
many ways that kind of nihilist nihilus
critique in in a softened way remains
very much a part of the the the
tremendous sense of kind of populist
discontent
that we that we hear so much about today
right you draw on a number of bodies of
literature so clearly you do have an
interest in literature and how how does
this how do the works illustrate the
point your child wonderful I'm glad you
asked me that because in many ways the
book for me at least I mean it breaks a
lot of new ground are not most of my
work is in the area of political
philosophy in that tradition but
literature I've canvassed a number of
works of literature which I think in
many ways give extremely vivid
expression to these philosophic and
political currents that I've been
talking about so for example the first
chapter of the book where I'm beginning
to outline the case and sort of make the
case for the for the modern bourgeois
begins with it with a play by
Machiavelli we don't usually think of
Machiavelli the playwright but I focus
on this play men dragula and the idea
what I think of is the idea of the
protiens self a person who's constantly
making and remaking and redoing
themselves which i think is very much
part of Machiavelli's language and it's
very much present in men dragged along
and then I I deal with several other
kinds of literary works again of the
autobiography of Benjamin Franklin which
is a of course an autobiography many
many people think it's it's don't work
of fiction in its own way making himself
as a literary hero but then I have
several novels I I have a I think flow
bear I have a chap matter chapter and
Madame Bovary no one put the problem of
the bourgeois more front-and-center than
did flow bear he he had a kind of just
aesthetic disgust for this figure and
it's represented by a particular figure
in his Madame Bovary
my name--a who's the town apothecary the
druggist in the town and he represents
everything that flow Barre despised a
kind of bull kind of
and prove the progressive views of
enlightenment public education public
health he's great advocate for public
health and for flow bear that's just
represented just a kind of Philistine
ism that was the outgrowth of the you
know heroic ideals of the French
Revolution here is what it's produced a
world of Philistine ISM and a kind of
low minded materialism but flow Barre is
a wonderful example and then the book
ends with two chapters on I think two
two extraordinary novels one that very
much characterizes this phenomenon of
the emergence of the bourgeois world is
won by an Italian novelist named plan
producer Giuseppe de Lampedusa his novel
gato Pardo the leopard which is a book
about an aristocrat is his ancestor his
based on his grandfather kind of
thoughtful aristocrat contemplating the
end of his order in Sicily and watching
the kind of emergence of the democratic
age at the time of the Italian
unification in 1870 and then the book
ends with a chapter of saw Bella one of
my very favorites modern writers called
mr. Sandler's planet written in about
1970 where that with a central character
who's a Holocaust survivor
finds himself living late in life on the
Upper West Side of Manhattan back in the
60s and 70s and contemplating the
question the book asks is here's a man
who's lived through the destruction of
one civilization is he seeing it again
taking place another time I actually
have a sort of a redemptive reading of
samlor I don't see it as completely
negative as many as many of the readers
do but I think these literary works
novels plays autobiographies are
absolutely central to shaping you know
the kinds of discs both celebration of
modernity and discontent with it that we
that we feel was it difficult for you in
terms of such a huge body of literature
out there in in choosing you know novels
and plays
to draw from to make your points it was
extremely difficult in mine my editor
and I had several angry fights about
what what should go in and the book is
long enough but it's considerably
shorter than the one that I originally
put in because there was so much you
know the topic is potentially endless
and my selections are admittedly
somewhat arbitrary they are for me a
kind of greatest hits album and it's in
a certain way of the books and works
that I think are most illustrative of
these themes but of it but they are the
works after my up my own tastes and my
own so you know anyone could take issue
why didn't you use the or to use this or
not that and so on but you're right that
was it was painful to to to edit myself
but you know you have to you have to end
somewhere you could have can't go on
nothing can go on forever so ultimately
what do you conclude in the book well
the conclusion is it would the
conclusion is in a sense that what what
I'm calling our discontents I have just
become almost a part of our mental and
cultural DNA they have become who we are
the idea that we we should we should
somehow get rid of these or we can
somehow grow out of them or just you
know kind of grow up and put these aside
is it is is it's not right it's not
going to happen to some degree
these discontents are a good thing the
discontents we feel a avoid teach us to
avoid complacency with with again a kind
of progressive astir narrative that we
hear so much about it
alerts us to areas of of domination and
control over our lives that that we
should be too and it just it just is it
is it get a certain kind of gain and
Inlet and although I don't want to
embrace the kind of radical nihilism
that I always talk
about for the most part there are a
number of people who represent what I
would think of as kind of moderate
discontent those being in the book
writers like Tocqueville Isaiah Berlin
Leo Strauss who very much understand the
problems with modernity and the culture
of the bourgeois but don't necessarily
think it needs to be rejected root and
branch rather it needs to be sustained
in in different ways by older traditions
of thought and older practices that can
help to sustain modernity without
without exactly throwing out the baby
with the bathwater so I end by arguing
actually we need to sort of embrace our
discontent and I think that's a that's
ultimately a good thing right okay
fascinating thank you so much for being
here with us today
who's my pleasure thank you Thank You
Marilyn for more information about
Professor Smith and his research please
visit our website at macmillan report
yale.edu
be sure to join us again for another
episode of the Macmillan report made
possible through funding from the
Whitney and Betty Macmillan Center for
International and area studies at Yale